[Music]
if you've watched any anime or played
any video games you probably recognize
my guest voice he is the narrator of
Dragon Ball Z Ryu from Street Fighter
and Ben and just about every anime as a
background voice for ground voice and
everything in the middle he has also
been known to die once or twice chasing
me around in the video Kiley bear is an
asshole but he is certainly anything but
please welcome the incredibly awesome
Kyle a bear how are you sir
I am awesome thanks so much for having
me man absolutely um I of course have to
start off with this question what does
happen next on Dragon Ball Z oh man
well apparently a bunch of little kids
get together and they want to lynch me
because they know when they hear my
voice that it usually means the episode
is at an end we have to find out next
time
but luckily if they tuned it at the
right time then they'll go this time
coming up next on you know oh good I
tuned it at just the right time you know
I come home from from school i watch key
kid I'm in there and then okay good good
all right I didn't miss anything except
the fact that we're gonna loop the
animation and keep it going for 3,000
episodes and power up forever I
apologize I didn't understand any of
that because you were not doing your
narrator oh do something similar just in
the narrator okay here's what I do I
summarized the last episode of Dragon
Ball Z and then other cool stuff happens
and then what's gonna happen next find
out now and then it does bad I heard
that was very nicely ah thank you thank
you
you started with a radio
Disney and you worked your way into
voice acting how does that transition
happen how'd you get into it at all well
a lot of radio people actually
transition because it's you know from
one padded room to the other behind a
mic by yourself but it's it's just a
lifelong love of the thrill of the
theater of the mind learning a blue knee
tunes as a kid hearing that you know one
guy voiced all those characters of my
favorite characters Bugs Bunny and Daffy
Duck all those guys it's like wow that's
a job I want that job so I quickly
decided as a kid probably eight years
old that this is what I wanted to do I
was painfully shy and so I would just
take a cassette recorder and have a play
radio station I would do you like parody
ads and stuff and I play kiss records on
my turntable back then in 1978 play all
right Kate y le FM and I could do all
that come out and be all crazy zany and
stuff than this quiet reserved kid who
like wasn't very popular and you know
kind of kept to himself and everything
but I I was fascinated by that idea that
maybe you could entertain or reach a
vast audience somehow with just your
voice that always intrigued me so I
ended up not doing any theatre which is
what any voice actor will tell you don't
do please don't do what I do kids you do
need an acting background and everything
and I ended up doing it kind of
backwards I got cast on Dragon Ball Z
and then I ended up taking classes and
improv after the fact but luckily that
didn't prove whatever skills I
apparently had so it did work out for
the best but that's that's not the path
I would suggest people doing every path
is unique so I ended up getting work
getting a Bachelor of Arts degree in
radio radio TV film in the University of
North Texas grew up in Dallas I got an
internship with ABC Radio Networks and
worked for several years on everything
from classic country to top 40 to mid
the road or big band stuff to heavy
metal and then kids radio radio at his
team thought I've intro every kind of
record there is and on Radio Disney I
was doing particularly my own kind of
style as a DJ which was kind of like a
blend of Jim Carrey and Robin Williams
so and I had the creative freedom to
just go crazy I used to have a partner
Kara Edwards who voices Goten and Vidal
my little brother and girlfriend
how's that for awkward on Dragonball Z
so we did a team show together and we
acted like we were in on a spaceship so
we had sound effects and music beds and
everything and we knew we weren't
fooling anyone but it was just fun to do
a theater of the mind like radio drama
type thing and I was writing producing
doing all that heard about auditions for
Dragon Ball Z and it's like oh my god I
love that show I was already a fan of
the show from previously here Shafer of
years had been airing it's like oh my
god that's recorded here in Dallas what
whoa
mind blown so I heard about auditions
from some station co-workers who were
working to secure the rights to give
away merchandise like what's the hottest
thing on TV right now
Dragon Ball Z we should talk to those
people they're in town yeah so we ended
up giving away Dragon Ball Z toys and
merch and meanwhile I kind of got in the
back door it said hey can I try it out
for this yeah go ahead
what acting experience do you have like
I work for Radio Disney yeah that counts
good get in the booth so I open a
three-ring binder and looking through
characters and it's like I recognize go
on right away cuz I'm a fan of the show
and I'm looking at other things like
just pick like a half a dozen characters
whoever you want to read for like okay
for these get in the booth didn't get
cast as go on right away
there were several months away from that
arc I'm the new guy right so they start
new guys doing bit-part voices because
lipstick is a very technical skill you
gotta be able to act take direction and
match the mouth flaps if you don't then
it's not going to work you could have
people Shakespearean trained veterans
get in the booth and then they freaked
because you have that little starting
gun act and they throw some people off
like baby I'll do act now
no no get out don't bring him back but
fortunately I guess I somehow fooled
them into believing that I could do this
so I wasn't nervous or anything it was
just like this is the opportunity of a
lifetime this is something I've
literally literally wanted since I was a
kid and I got to do it and I did a
little bit parts on the end of the dress
the the cell saga and the Bartok special
was the first thing to come out it had
my voice on it so I turned to little
kids like oh my god it's really
happening I'm not gonna lie here when
you're on Radio Disney the first thing I
think in myself is the Dragon Ball Z
voice doing like Mickey Mouse or
something like that did you ever do
anything we have like a different voice
for like a fluffy character well I did
get to like I said Jim Carrey Robin
Williams which are spastic to begin with
right so we're doing like infotainment
features in between the songs which
weren't actually all Disney songs except
for the preteen programming which we
would play you know the typical things
you think of when you think of Disney
but it was actually more of a top 40
just you know very safe family
consumption at the time let's see back
to the boy bands were starting to hit
Britney Spears all that stuff
Spice Girls all this was it was huge at
the time Weird Al of course a staple and
still is and yeah we had these little
features that would play in between the
songs and I was amongst the the
character voice staff as well as a DJ
and I would write these features such as
gross me out and I would you know or
aptitude dude which was a science guy
before Bill Nye or alongside I got ahead
of your time my friend a heavy right
that's right yeah yeah but I would do
like this surfer dude guy it's like
Johnny from Iowa wants to know why is
the sky blue
so I would just like surf it up man and
that was a lot of fun so it's if Cartman
was in fact a surfer
ye-yeah exactly and then we do like
their other features like let's go back
in time and this character would go back
in time and meet historical figures and
sometimes I would voice like you know it
was pretty or you know or Peabody and
Sherman yeah yes the Wayback Machine
there but I never do you know
trademarked voices like that when we had
Mickey and Minnie we actually got Mickey
and Minnie to to come in and all that so
that was pretty cool so I never got to
be like oh boy
it's never got to do that but it was a
great job I had so much fun you know
acting like I was on a spaceship
interviewing celebs like Will Smith and
Weird Al and and just having a blast
um did your doing Dragon Ball Z you're
doing all sorts of various animes and
voice work and stuff like that is there
ever a line or a scene because these
performances have to have some very
strange lines and was there ever a time
where you read a line he just burst out
laughing because it was so strange Oh
totally totally it is just very you
could say bad words right yes whatever
you want oh okay good I was recording on
Naruto
and I've always Kiba the kid with a dog
on his head and seen the dialogue
literally said something along the lines
of I'm gonna sneak in and take him from
behind with my all-fours jutsu right
because all the ninja kids have these
jutsus and I have no idea where this is
going at all right well I mean the only
direction I got from Mary Elizabeth
McGlynn who is a awesome director and
voice actress in Earlham right
directed me and her direction was simply
good luck so after five minutes of
trying not to laugh if we cut the dig
done it's like it really says that this
got approved like yeah that is what it
is but yeah and a lot of the times the
the outtakes don't make it out there
because you know the Japanese think that
we're making fun of their shows it's
just not necessarily the case we I mean
we don't get to study this stuff ahead
of time there's no rehearsals you don't
get the script ahead of time the only
thing I know is the
the time and the place and the project
usually it's like what am i doing today
and so Mary will say alright in this
episode your character is doing this and
then these guys are attacking the
village and noted in it and say okay so
bullet points you have to be able to to
think quick on your feet that's why
improv is so important that's what cold
reading is so important to be able to
read a script right then and there and
then performance and somehow make it
come to life and match the lip-sync in
the case of anime but you don't do the
Brando thing where you have the lines
actually on people's eyelids or no if I
did on camera I would totally I would
totally pull that I'd be like can you
just I saw that picture the infamous
picture from Godfather where Marlon
Brando sitting and it's got Robert
Duvall holding his coke jacket open and
he's wearing poster board with Brando's
lines for The Godfather on there it's
like that's how he did it
brilliant you you you do it easier you
can have the script right in front of
you and nobody watching so it's a little
cheating it is a little cheating and I'm
spoiled by it to be quite honest the
whole idea of voice acting is just like
don't look at me just hear what's coming
out of me and then hopefully it's not
you know which the mics pick up you try
to subtly fart that mic will pick it up
that mic will hear you I farted like
five times and nobody seems to notice no
one noticed but I mean if this were like
apologize for that by the way cuz you're
probably gonna go with oh yes I'm
basking in it actually okay that scares
me how much you're enjoying that oh I'm
sorry I don't sniff firts but anyway
Brett will pretend that didn't happen
anyway yeah exactly
no I mean that the great perk to voice
acting of course and maybe it's because
I've always just been introverted and
shy believe it or not is that your
script is in front of you there's no
rehearsal there's no memorization
involved there's no I'm cast because I
look like this I mean of course it
matters in the end
in voice vote and voices over not so
much which is very freeing you get to
come out of your skin and inhabit
someone else's skin for an hour five
minutes - you know whatever and you can
wear whatever I'm wearing my little
dashi station to pick up some power
converters shirt but it doesn't matter
doesn't matter that looked like this
when I could voice a teenager or a voice
an old man or drill sergeant or monster
that dies in - you know lines or
whatever I mean that's just like the
coolest job ever to me we're talking
beforehand about the if you've ever done
a on camera where you said you've played
some extras my first thought is you
would not blend into the background or
because you are just so distinct I mean
you can just ha figured from the airport
it's just like you know principally a
mile away I can see I mean I can just
identify you right away and you were
saying that there was always a
possibility for commercial or on screen
work but that didn't interest you as
much not as much I think it's fun I mean
I'm a huge pop-culture nerd I love
movies and television I grew up on it as
we all have and we consume the media and
everything and I love those
opportunities but yeah my passion first
and foremost is get behind the mic not
in front of the camera behind the camera
is interesting - I think it's very
interesting too you know post-production
work special effects directing it's
that's fascinating to see I was an extra
on the third Pirates of the Caribbean
movie now I wasn't actually and in the
final cut but I was paid for two days
work and I saw Gore Verbinski on set and
he looked like totally like calm and
relaxed it's like this you know this 50
million dollar budget is on this one
guy's shoulders and he's just like yeah
alright let's do this and do this and
granted he's a veteran director but I
can't imagine you know trying to balance
all of that under think but it's like a
jigsaw puzzle coming together in the
voice-over world you sit in the booth
for eight hours a day as the actors come
in one at a time because you have to for
anime and video games because of
technical constraints to match the
timing of the Japanese audio or the
timing of the video the mouth sink and
all that that's that's pretty
interesting I haven't had the
opportunity to do direct
but I would probably pounce on it just
to say yeah all right did it you've
worked with Street Fighter several years
now and a lot of people identify you
with that one certain character which of
course I have to ask the question that
you probably get asked the most how do
you say his name is there B you is Ryu
is I've heard every way growing up and
every single way I say it somebody tells
me it's wrong so I didn't hear from the
actual voice actor how you say his name
Gertrude miles way off way off way off
now when I recorded Capcom said it's Ryu
it's not Hadouken it's hot' dokkan and I
don't bother correcting fans you know if
that's how they want to say it you know
but in my case I'm a voice actor I have
to say it how they tell me to say it or
else I don't get paid so they'd say
peanut butter jelly time yeah I'll say
peanut butter jelly time and do it with
great her own but yeah I mean God man a
landing an iconic role like like that
just being in Street Fighter is it's
pretty awesome I lost many quarters on
that now I still suck at it button mash
button mash button mash it's like oh you
need strategy for this oh crap I have
none zero skills goose egg
but the Ryu thing yeah they told me it's
Ryu recording for Street Fighter and the
multiple incarnations ever since then
but honestly my favorite achievement in
my career so far is 10 seconds long and
it's Ryu in wreck-it Ralph for Disney
because that's another personal
achievement unlocked kind of thing it's
like I want a voice for cartoons one day
and of course you know who doesn't want
to be in a Disney film who doesn't want
to be in an awesome Disney film like Toy
Story for gamers
that's what wreck-it Ralph is to me and
I love Toy Story and everyone says froze
and frozen like No
man wreckit-ralph wrecker l was the
original frozen that's right yes kind of
in a way I can't think of yeah let it go
let it go I'm a bad guy well I lose my
next question what was the Disney
experience like because I mean we both
have something in common that flip was
bought by maker maker was bought by
Disney so we both work for the same
tyrannical overlord say these have
worked for them but at the same time I
can't help but love my tyrannical
overlords maybe it's a yes
you know you love your kidnappers or
something like that but even before then
I always enjoy Disney and I always hear
you know both incredibly good and no you
just you're incredibly good stuff abound
like the stuff that people say is bad I
hear it a lot of times as played of so
what was your experience with them well
it felt like a circle of life queer sort
of thing see what I did nicely done
Yeah right right oh but yeah I mean
working for Disney on the radio side of
it first and I told the producers of
wreck-it Ralph when I was you know
recording with them that's like wow
really used to be for radio Tuesday's
like yeah yeah this is like full circle
this is wild to me then working for
Marvel which is now owned by Disney for
Avengers a few years ago Earth's
Mightiest Heroes Disney will just own
every per day plan they got on us they
got Marvel I mean it's only a man
looketh yeah they got caution stations
so yeah so it's I just have a Mickey
Mouse shirt under this I'm gonna whip
out at the very end Oh what that'd be
swell never do that again I will never
do that again that is highly disturbing
but continue with your story I had a
story oh yeah what's working for the
Disney overlords no it was surreal
because I live in Burbank in Disney
Studios in Burbank so not even five
minutes from where I live I go to the
studio I didn't think that I would be
seeing john c reilly or Sarah Silverman
or all that because they recorded
separately as well but like anime and
video games I was brought in by myself
the director rich Moore was the only one
there in the booth with me and looking
at a music stand with a single piece of
paper
that had my little cameo in it and
recorded just by myself and he explained
what the scene was without showing it to
me because it I guess it wasn't animated
yet it was like this was July of 2012
the movie came out in November and we
recorded and then I said did you want me
to do any like oh good you know that's
like yeah sure why not because it wasn't
written into the into the Cameo and I go
okay well I did like two or three it's
like thank you so much it's so cool Ryu
came in it's like you're freaking out
over it it's my job to freak out I'm the
one who's here and you know why
so like yeh job security but two weeks
pass and they call my agent my agent
calls me and it's like yeah doesn't he
want you back it's like really for what
that's like well you're still gonna do
the same thing but they rewrote it like
oh okay
go in the jokes funnier it's like I said
it and then the director goes um yeah so
remember how you did the Hadouken the
animators actually did Aishwarya good so
can you give me that instead like oh
absolutely
so we did that then a third time a
couple weeks passed by and then a fourth
time and that's the one that ends up in
the final cut and then the last time
last time no sorry I go on the Disney
lot and now this time the movie is
pretty much done and they show it to me
on this on the screen and this is like
three months before final theatrical
release and we're
so cool and I'm on the place where they
like the recorded sound of music and the
next Mary Poppins and all this all this
Grich film history on the soundstage and
they said yeah Sarah Silverman's coming
in later today to record some last
minute you know stuff and say oh cool
so I didn't get to meet any of the cast
just work with a director which was
awesome and and I thought okay well this
is a cameo they're gonna cut it it's not
you know it's not gonna end up in the
final film it has nothing to do with the
story and then they release a press
release saying we got the original voice
actors for Sonic and we're you and they
add BIOS and everything it's like oh I
guess I did make the final cut okay this
is pretty awesome
so you know what's that came out and of
course I blabbed on social media it's
like Oh finally I could talk about it
this is awesome
outside of my I think my Facebook post
had all I'm Rio in record route like
five postings but like twelve straight
days it was impressive I mean I pride
myself on being humble but man I didn't
want to seem like I was bragging but I
was I was proud of it because it just
felt like when you have a dream I have a
dream as a kid
and then it comes to life when you're an
adult that doesn't happen all the time
and when it happened to me it was just
amazing and you know I got to see it in
the theater with Steve bloom one of my
voice actor mentors and and idols and
champions who's helped me get
established in Los Angeles ever since I
moved there like 2005 we were at a con
together in Nebraska anime Nebraska and
we we took that Friday in November to go
to the theater and watch wreck-it Ralph
and he and some staffers and me we're
all watching it and they they see or
hear the cameo it's like yeah they're
like clapping and they we stay after the
credits and there's my name and it's
like Kylie bear Ryu when you applauded
where any of the audience members behind
you like drunks you know come on shut up
you and then all my friends were like
posting on Facebook saying hey we
cheered for you you know we
we're in another state altogether but we
didn't care we said wow that's good way
to go Kyle and I meant so much to me
even though it's just a short you know
two lines but yeah just uh that's my
proudest achievement I had I had a PBS
commercial that showed in theaters
briefly and my wife got so excited that
she accidentally spilled the drink all
over me getting up to go the concession
stand to clean myself off she pointed
said that's my husband who is up there
that's my husband like don't do that
funny so I understand the excitement
definitely yeah yeah and it still
happens people's like and they they're
shoving a blu-ray or a DVD of wreck-it
Ralph and say I'm signing something
Disney this is weird
awesomely weird but weird that's like oh
man I hope that they they call again
sometimes that would be great was ever
disagreement over doing that voice
because on the one hand yeah it's a
director answer Phil but on the other
hand it's kind of your character that
you've done for a year so when you say
you know can you do a hot dog get know
it's hot okay did you ever get those big
did you ever come to blows no actually
no because the director he called me Ryu
Hadouken it's like all right I don't
have to correct him and I wouldn't
correct him and I said yeah I can get
the other cast members if there's any
more Street Fighter people you know it's
like no no we're good we're good
and then that turns out that Zangief was
voiced by himself the director took the
role from the actor which I feel sorry
for him but but you have to love him
he's Disney and he's your director
that's right and he's my director and
rich please call me I don't know what
he's working on but I would love to come
back for you dude I won't wreck it Ralph
- let's make a sequel let's just do this
I am I think everybody in the world is
waiting for that movie right now next -
Avengers - that's the sequel like
everybody is waiting for Incredibles -
yes yeah well that one is happening so
yeah where there's some good
superhero stuff coming out that way
you'll be a part of and I could go on
and on about that I'm a big nerd I eat
drink and sleep and breathe all this
stuff I love it um a lot beginning voice
talents they think majority of work is
like you know sort of the leading roles
of the supporting roles or even past
psyche characters and a lot of times
it's just people in the background or
you'll see a lot of really big voice
actors and they'll have these big roles
but they'll also have voice or
additional voice our background voice or
so on and so forth how much of that is
it starring roles how much of it is
background stuff I'd say a majority are
either episodic or bit parts and this is
true for almost any actor any lead role
guy on a show whether it's anime or
cartoon or games are probably gonna also
be doing soldier a and Monster B and and
and whatnot if you have a discerning
enough year you could probably you know
hear things like you know even in the
cartoon world I'll hear like Kevin
Conroy who's Batman but also here and be
like a cop in a scene or or like someone
else in the background it's like I think
I came in Conroy just be someone else
that's kind of funny what is in your
opinion someone let's dial a voice over
work what is the secret to getting
called back man oh I wish it were that
simple you know there's so many factors
that are out of your control that's why
it we emphasize to everyone who is
up-and-coming and curious about the
career and all that it's like get that
Foundation and hone those skills because
you never know when that door of
opportunities going to open up and if if
you go in and have a great audition and
they cast you then that the pressure is
kind of on you know like what if you
can't replicate what you gave them and
can you capture that lightning in a
bottle again oops oh geez that's why
it's we tell people it's so important
that you're trained to they take
direction well you improvise you're good
cold reader you think on the feed that
you're moldable and flexible and direct
a bowl and your humble and nice that's
kind of pretty important being nice and
remembering your roots and all that and
don't let any success get to your head
stay grounded and love what you do
you know and that's that's kind of the
be-all-end-all the kind of mantra that I
tell people when I go to conventions and
everything it's like find your passion
and do it if you can make a living doing
something you love life doesn't get any
better than that
don't go into this going I'm gonna be a
voice actor because I want to be rich
and famous it's like know that that's
the wrong motivation
speaking of conventions you are
practically doing that almost it's like
your second living cuz you do so many I
do I mean it what was it like 30 this
year or something something ridiculous
yeah there's a few weekends where I'm
actually home and it feels weird when
I'm looking it's like this Saturday
afternoon how do I have a panel no wait
I'm home I can actually just go out with
my friends or I can just sit at home and
Netflix it or hang out whatever yeah I'm
I do a lot of traveling and I love it I
look it's exhausting and I'm jet-lagged
don't get me wrong but getting to meet
the fans this is like icing on the cake
getting to see new places that I've
never been to before because you know
I'm so fortunate to get to do something
that I love and also fortunate that
people like what I do as well and so
they hey we want to bring you out like
all right excellent let's do this so
yeah I've been in Australia Ireland
England Australia and and you know all
points in between here in the States and
in Canada and it's it's it's truly
amazing and hearing people's stories
that come and shake your hand or give
you a hug and they tell you it's a hey
you were great in that role or something
maybe more intimate and personal just
like you helped me get over depression
or I lost a family member or a Pat and I
was grieving and your character and such
a such game or show really helped me get
through that to the dark times or
soldiers or incarcerated people you know
prisoners here it's like man you know I
got you know six more months left to go
on my sentence and you know I've yet to
have that one just you wait
it will happen but I mean everything
people turn their touching stories and
terminal kids terminal patients I mean
I've heard and seen just about
everything there is and it's like wow
you don't think about it at the time
when you're in a booth recording you're
in a little vacuum it's just you and the
engineer and the director and maybe
someone from the client
and that's it and this quiet little
booth in a microphone you're doing it
and you're the take maybe two or three
takes later and they go great okay move
on and then after that okay great
session great to see you hugs and then
you go on to your life right and then
six months a year later in the case of
some gains
you know Street Fighter was out for I
you know took a year to to bring that
the dub version out you have no idea
what sort of impact is gonna have and
then now there's there's so much going
on first world problem I mean so many
games Rose that you know I was either
I'd go on games.com or you know or I'll
hear from fans on Twitter it's like
great job on someone so and I go oh
that's out check Google like oh it's out
why thank you yes i boy so and so in
this game I've been sitting on it for
years like pull out the smartphone and
open the note-taking app and I'll save
the day that I'm recording I'll write
the name of the character the name of
the project and I'll save it and then
I'll wait till it's out and then you're
talking about before he hears from a lot
of voice actors people who if they go to
a recording studio and sometimes it's
just then sometimes they work with a
giant cast is it just give and take on
different productions or is there kind
of a norm with games in anime they do
pretty much require you to be solo again
because the technical constraints of
matching the animation or perhaps if
it's a Japanese game then you got to
match the timing of the audio because
the audio in Japanese is what's being
used to time with the animation but the
animation is not done yet for the game
you only have the audio with cartoons
though the animation is not done yet so
you get to play off each other's
performance of reactor gets their own
mic and stand and you get to perform
together maybe not the whole cast
because not everyone is always available
at the same time but it's fascinating
and it's entertaining as hell to watch
people you know screw up their lives
just like you do and you get to watch
their process and it's fascinating it's
really cool and everyone's having a good
time they're professional they bring
their a-game and then it's like it's
like a little
miniature party and then you go back to
your life and like oh man I want to do
that again it's like crack bring me in
but it does depend on the project I mean
I never heard of a whole cast recording
an anime not on the dub side of it
anyway
and then did that just be a lot of your
turn your turn your maybe end up wasting
money that you know the the budgets are
so low anyway as it is that you know why
pay a bunch of actors to stand around
waiting for one guy to finish the
lip-sync that's why you bring in
everyone separately so you can record
maybe a DVDs worth of episodes over the
course of a couple weeks maybe and yep
you have to schedule all those actors
and juggle times back and forth and be
flexible make sure that you know you
have the time to go from point A to
point B and then meanwhile you're
juggling auditions that come in daily
and record from home and you know that's
what my typical day is I do a lot of
auditions from home and wait for that
call or that email going hey you know
you know your cast is so-and-so we need
you to x' day 9:00 to 11:00 oh sweet and
put that in the calendar of the phone
and then boom lather rinse repeat
well not know yeah I lost this years ago
so now it's more like shine which you
probably this is probably really glowing
so if we had baby powder I wouldn't be
quite as you know we actually were using
the top of your head for the focus I
hope you don't take oh no no that's
totally cool I helped with the amount of
people that you must have worked with
over the years who are the ones that you
just had the most fun with or you looked
up to just who were the big like the
most fun recordings for you oh man I
recorded for a Verizon commercial years
ago and I was cut from it so I didn't
get to have that fun but recording with
Gradle I'll and Billy West and
unfortunately I don't remember who the
other actors worked because I was too
busy being blown away that it was like
great a lot it's awesome and she's she's
wonderful and sweet but Billy West as
another huge Idol
I look up to and he's a great
storyteller and he's got this manic
energy and you just it's just infectious
to be in the same room we all recorded
together because our character is in
this commercial we're singing was on the
island of the misfit toys from the whole
claymation Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer and at the time the iPhone
wasn't available on Verizon so they they
made this whole joke and had a
stop-motion commercial and they had the
iPhone on the island of misfit toys I
thought it was kind of cute
but the animation wasn't done yet we
were just doing the voices so he was
voicing like The Lion the ruler of the
island of misfit toys I was the
choo-choo train but they ended up
cutting the choo-choo train from its but
yeah the recording experience was cool
because that's rare too to have all the
actors together like that for a
commercial and how the commercial
actually have a song in it and I don't
remember how the song went but that was
a pretty unique experience I definitely
know us I'm sure other people know us
you're a big advocator against pirating
anime you've gone out talked about that
before
um and I always hear me personally I
hear mix things I hear some people say
it's spreading the word a lot I hear
other people say it's really taking a
big bite out of the industry is there
which side is more truthful as they're
true to either just what's your take I
think I think now you know the Internet
has changed the way we consume media
overall it's changed the face of
everything it's changed the job
structure has changed the business
models and everything and in the case of
anime Japan you know you have Studios
that go under because people are just
downloading the shows instead of buying
them when they come out and but now you
see a business model with things like
Funimation crunchyroll viz they're
putting shows online as soon as they're
broadcast with subtitles they're
officially available and they're either
you know pay for a subscription model or
free with streaming ads so you know at
least there's money going back into the
system and I think that's a good
compromise and you know it's a global
marketplace and Japan kind of needs the
US and other countries of the world all
work together so they continue
the show's out so the soapbox that I get
on it's like if you consider yourself a
fan you support that project or the
product or band or whatnot with your
dollars you go see a band you like in
concert I mean yeah everyone and
everyone's guilty of it too
you know if you can let's do an album
for free just by a couple of clicks yeah
you do it we're a try it before you buy
it Society so but because anime is such
a niche thing that it's only like 1% of
the entertainment spectrum that's why
piracy affects it so badly Wolverine
Origins released in DVD quality before
the theatrical release didn't impact it
at all it was still number one in
theaters when it came out and then
quickly everyone saw why it was terrible
and never go see it again but you know
you put on a show that cost millions of
dollars to produce or hundreds of
thousands or whatever and then it gets
distributed out there and it's seen in
the fan and the fan base is rabid about
it and then you know they don't think
about spending money on it
because you know it's oh it cost too
much and yet all the people who
complained about this is the reason why
I pirate because it cost too much to buy
the DVDs that meanwhile they're they're
saving their money which they should
anyway if there's something worth buying
you save your money right and they're
tweeting from their their smartphone and
they got their big screen HDTV and all
that's like I can't afford a DVD like
really really can we think that but now
it's it's a better time than ever to be
an anime fan with with crunchyroll
Funimation other other subscriptions
where they're throwing out free episodes
I mean they're giving fans a pretty fair
shake it's like here here's the first
volume watch it for free
and if you like it consider a
subscription you know and the Netflix
you know at least for the states and
then Canada to a degree as well you know
there it's never been a better time an
anime has never been cheaper for mass
consumption and legally - we both have
worked with little group we know as team
four stars yes for those who don't know
they do they read up
animation particularly Dragonball Z they
read of anime and we have both had the
pleasure of working both of them hanging
out with them with something like that
when you see them taking something that
is somebody else's work but redoubling
it do you say to yourself well that's
them turning it into something else or
do you still see uh some form of
copyright infringement again well what's
your take on it that's a legal gray area
because I guess technically by the
letter of the contracts and all the
legality of it yes it is copyrighted
visual material that is being altered
and manipulated it kind of like sampling
is to music you know it's like Ice Ice
Baby no it's under pressure whatever but
I mean the fascinating thing is you know
team four star with Dragon Ball Z
abridged has happened to create a new
fan base there's people that never
watched Dragon Ball Z before until they
saw the parody of it I would argue that
the parody is more popular than the show
itself that's a pretty interesting thing
and those guys you know pack rooms like
like there's nobody's business
you know there's a hugely popular and
they're hysterical they're great they're
great bunch of dudes and ladies working
on on those parodies and I can't wait to
see what original material they come up
with you know I'm afraid to see whatever
tool material to come up with because
let me tell you I've seen their I see
more the abridge than I have the
original show okay and it has actually
made me want to watch the original show
just so I can find out where this voyage
came from it was like the stuff they do
is scary okay scary stuff but by God if
I'm not constantly looking forward to
the next one yeah and and it gets a
little walkie if you have the fans
coming up to you asking you to quarter
to bridge loss I'm not that going on I'm
not go up in the actual show so it's a
little strange but I mean it's also cool
so I view it as a good positive thing
it's it's entertaining it's really
really funny I don't know what toy is
for you huh it is probably like No curse
you but then you have the Napster
Metallica thing all over again it's like
do you really
shoot your fanbase in the foot like that
it's like let's let's work together I
like to end every interview with the
same two polar opposite questions the
first one being whether professional or
personally what is the toughest thing
you ever had to go through and how did
you get through it the toughest thing I
had to go through was moving well it's a
Los Angeles from Dallas because I never
envisioned myself moving I thought that
maybe I would just be in Dallas my whole
life but then I quickly realized that
all the cartoon work is really in LA I
mean Funimation's there and that they're
great and they're awesome and they got
my start in the career but I don't see
myself making a living doing that and
the scariest thing I had to do was walk
away from a full-time job with Radio
Disney you know good decent pay and good
benefits and and look at I'm gonna leave
everyone I know and love behind and
gamble it on moving to Los Angeles which
many many thousands and thousands and
thousands people do for whatever reason
or you pick up and move to any other
city for a job opportunity and it's the
scariest thing I ever did and my family
or both
and still are tremendously supportive of
what I do they don't understand it they
think that the freelance life is is way
too unpredictable and they are right
there right but they know how much it
meant to me and you know I remember
distinctly going cross-country from
Dallas in a moving truck with my dad he
helped me get set up and all that I
bought him a one-way ticket home to fly
and and what happened was you know as
soon as I dropped him off I pulled over
the side of the road and cried like a
baby so hard harder than I ever had in
my life ever because I said oh my god
I'm here I'm actually doing this this is
the scariest thing I've ever done I went
broke within months I didn't have a day
job I did some internet radio
post-production and maybe some radio
imaging you know the guys you say like
fm so 103.7 the station was I did a
little of that but it was hardly
anything to sustain myself that was the
scariest time ever just going broke
going
my god I mean it's not that I my myself
in terms of talent I always thought that
if I had the opportunity that I think
everything would work out and I see I
thought it was a matter of time but boy
that was rough
boy that was scary to do you know call
my parents call my friends going you
know yeah how you doing not so good not
so good um let me pay rent by getting a
new credit card and running it up let me
go further in debt so yeah kids don't do
as I do it's it's a bad idea to do that
so if you're gonna move to a new city
save your money save like 10 grand so
you can float for a little bit while you
look for work because if you're gonna be
an actor or something creative an
animator an artist you know YouTube
celeb whatever I mean you got to you got
to think about this it's like okay got
planned things out it's like it's this
gonna be a ramen night or can I splurge
and have Taco Bell I had a friend it was
an acting teacher who always used to say
here's the most important book you'll
ever read if you want to be an actor it
says how to wait tables right because
you always have to start I mean from
nothing pretty much you know nobody
very few start with everything at your
beck and call for any much one going
into acting yeah and if you if you move
to Hollywood you're a little fish in a
big pond and it's really true what they
say I mean no matter how much success
you had in another city you feel like
it's a clean slate and you're starting
over from the from the get-go I felt
like the five years at the time that I
had started with Funimation I thought oh
my god
this doesn't matter this doesn't matter
at all but I had friends I was friends
with Steve Blum who stills one of the
most wonderful human beings hint in the
world and a fantastic voice actor who
who took me under his belt and said dude
it's gonna be fine just wait it out I
know it's tough but we all go through it
and he walked my demo into a couple
studios and that helped light the spark
which took years before I would I would
get you know somewhat regular work but I
stuck it out it meant
much to me to say you know what every
time I get in the booth and I get to
record it makes all the suffering and
the sweating and they him and oh my god
I can't believe it it makes it worth it
it absolutely makes it worth it and I
will be that way till I die you know I
love what I do that much that I will I
will I will face whatever because it's
feast or famine as a freelancer anyone
who does self-employed anything knows
that to be the case you could have a
good month followed by three bad ones
you know a lucrative year followed by
five bad ones you know it mean there's
no rhyme or reason to it and there's
almost no momentum I've had momentum
over the course of eight or nine years
but it's not a steady momentum it's not
like I am suddenly working every day
because I'm not I'm auditioning more
than I'm working still most actors that
is the case but I stuck it out and I'm
glad I did that was the hardest thing I
did though was was to leave my home and
come to a brand new place where I didn't
know anyone basically just by myself
since then I move my daughter out she
lives with me still and it's working and
finally again either professionally or
personally what is the proudest thing
you've ever done in your life well this
will sound like a cop-out answer because
we have already discussed this I was
hoping you think of something else
oh Jesus a car and there's so much
emotional stuff there and they just get
it oh I'm just gonna repeat a yeah okay
well discovering discovering this thing
called better than peanut butter because
it's natural and creaming you put it in
the refrigerator after you open it
because I don't know science but it
really is better than peanut butter
you're gonna end this interview on that
weak-ass answer I mean wreck-it Ralph
I'm in wreck-it Ralph I got to be in a
Disney movie which you didn't hear that
part right cuz you scrubbed over it
blended it out ahhh better than peanut
butter though
atashi station power aren't you
[Music]
this has been cut away merit this has
been shown to thank you thank you this
is where we talk to each other you don't
like the camera still good
I know really I mean it's like so weak
especially emotional I know I know it's
like whoa
yeah just down down the toilet total
yeah I wish I'd never met you right now
totally completely
[Laughter]